So Parker, let's talk about our disagreement about the Jews.
帕克，我们来谈谈关于犹太人的分歧吧。
It's not a disagreement about Jewish people, Ira.
艾拉，这并不是关于犹太人的分歧。
Listen to how you said that.
听听你是怎么说的。
What did I say? I said Jewish people.
我说了什么？我说的是犹太人（Jewish people）。
You mean the Jews?
你是说犹太佬（the Jews）？
Jewish people.
犹太人。
The Jews.
犹太佬。
Jewish people. I mean, I get the irony of me telling you it's Jewish people, but it's Jewish people.
犹太人。我是说，我知道我纠正你该说“犹太人”这一点很讽刺，但确实应该是“犹太人”。
That's Parker, one of my coworkers here at This American Life, and our disagreement about the Jews/Jewish people started a couple of months ago here at our radio show. A bunch of us, including Parker, were going through a script together. It was about white nationalists, and the script had a sentence where the reporter used the word Jews. The reporter is not a Jew. Parker and another young staffer both literally gasped.
那是帕克，我在这里《美国生活》的一位同事，我们关于“犹太佬/犹太人”的争论始于几个月前我们的广播节目里。当时我们一群人，包括帕克，正在一起审读一份脚本。内容是关于白人民族主义者的，脚本里有一句话，记者用了“犹太佬”（Jews）这个词。那个记者本人不是犹太人。帕克和另一位年轻员工都真地倒吸了一口冷气。
Well, yeah, because the term, Jew, depending on the person, can be viewed as a slur.
嗯，是的，因为“犹太佬”这个词，取决于不同的人，可能会被视为一种侮辱性称呼。
Can I just say, buddy.
我能说句实话吗，老兄。
Yeah.
嗯。
I'm a Jew.
我就是个犹太人。
I know.
我知道。
I'm over 50.
我都50多岁了。
That's true.
那是事实。
And can I just say, I didn't get the memo on this one.
我能说，我完全没收到过关于这一点的通知吗。
It's a generational thing, man.
这是代沟问题，老兄。
When did you hear it?
你是什么时候听说的？
I think, all my life.
我想，我一直都知道。
I don't know how I missed out on this one. As a Jew-- excuse me. As one of the Jewish people, you'd think I would be the first to know. I don't find the word "Jew" offensive. Apparently, though, I am out of step on this one. Noted.
不知道我怎么会错过这个。作为一名犹太人——抱歉。作为“犹太人”的一员，你以为我会是第一个知道的人。我不觉得“犹太佬”这个词有什么冒犯性。不过显然，在这件事上我落伍了。记下了。
There were, in this case, no dire consequences. Nobody's feelings were hurt. Nobody felt judged. That's not how the story usually goes.
在这种情况下，并没有造成什么严重的后果。没人感到受伤。没人觉得被评判。事情通常不是这样发展的。
And today, on our program, we have the more typical thing. We have two stories where people used the wrong word, and there are big consequences. Big, angry, judgy, divisive fights.
今天在我们的节目中，我们谈谈更典型的情况。我们有两个故事，人们用了错误的词，结果引发了严重的后果。充满了愤怒、评判和分裂的争吵。
And what's interesting in both of these stories is that these fights are among people who basically agree about most things-- who basically are allies. They want the same things, but then, somebody uses a word, and it's like, boom! I'm on this side. You're on that side. We are not on the same side. It's war, and we just get there so fast these days. This happens so often.
这些故事有趣的地方在于，这些争吵发生在那些在大多数问题上基本达成共识的人们之间——他们本是盟友。他们想要的是同样的东西，但随后，有人用了一个词，就像，砰！我站在这一边。你站在那一边。我们不再是一路人了。变成了战争，我们现在陷入这种境地太快了。这种情况太常发生了。
The first half of our show today is about words that have to do with sex. The second half is words that have to do with guns. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
我们今天节目的上半部分是关于与性有关的词汇。下半部分是关于枪支的词汇。来自WBEZ芝加哥电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act 1, Video Killed the Video Star. Laci Green is a YouTube star in her 20s. Because of that, people take shots at her. No surprise. Perhaps you've heard how the internet works. What is surprising is how over time, the kinds of people taking shots at her changed until she was under fire from the last people she expected, because they objected to certain words that she was saying.
第一幕，视频杀死了录影带明星。蕾西·格林是一位20多岁的YouTube明星。正因如此，人们总是抨击她。这不足为奇。或许你听说过互联网是如何运作的。令人惊讶的是，随着时间的推移，抨击她的人群发生了变化，直到她受到了她最意想不到的人群的猛烈抨击，因为他们反对她所说的某些词汇。
Before we start this story, I want to pile up the warnings here, OK? This is a story about offensive language, so it is just chock-full of potentially offensive words. If you're not into that, don't listen to the story. This story not only acknowledges the existence of sex, it specifies some of the body parts involved-- probably not right for little kids. We have un-beeped the story here on the podcast. If you prefer the beeped version, there's one at our website. Our reporter is Kelefa Sanneh.
在开始这个故事之前，我想先堆叠一些警告，好吗？这是一个关于冒犯性语言的故事，所以它充满了潜在的冒犯性词汇。如果你不喜欢，就不要听这个故事。这个故事不仅承认性的存在，还具体提到了涉及的身体部位——可能不适合小孩。我们在播客中没有消音。如果你喜欢消音版本，我们的网站上有。我们的记者是凯勒法·萨内。
So, if you want to be a YouTube celebrity, it helps to have a niche. Here's Laci Green's niche.
所以，如果你想成为YouTube名人，找个利基领域很有帮助。这就是蕾西·格林的领域。
Well hi, babes. Let's talk about losing your virginity. The first thing you need to know about losing your virginity-- the foreskin is a highly elastic piece of skin that covers the head of the penis, and it's amazing. Aha! You've come to the right place. I'm kind of a vibrator connoisseur. When do I not want to talk about boobs? Boobs are great. Everyone loves them. I think if there's one thing that could bring world peace, it's probably boobs.
大家好，宝贝们。我们来谈谈失去童贞。关于失去童贞你需要知道的第一件事——包皮是一层覆盖在阴茎头上极具弹性的皮肤，它非常神奇。啊哈！你找对地方了。我算是某种按摩棒鉴赏家。什么时候我不想谈论胸部呢？胸部很棒。每个人都喜欢它们。我认为如果有一件事能带来世界和平，那可能就是胸部。
You can tell she loves this stuff. She gets animated when she talks about sex and relationships and genitalia. It feels like her face was designed for YouTube-- very expressive features, and she includes footnotes on screen, like each video is a cheerful, little seminar. My producer, Zoe Chace, and I called her to talk about her first big hit.
看得出她热爱这些东西。她在谈论性、人际关系和生殖器时会变得生动起来。感觉她的脸就是为YouTube设计的——非常具有表现力的五官，而且她在屏幕上包含脚注，就像每个视频都是一个欢快的小研讨会。我的制片人佐伊·蔡斯和我打电话给她，谈论她第一个大火的视频。
Yeah, the first sex ed video that I made that went viral was called You Can't Pop Your Cherry, and it was about the hymen.
是的，我制作的第一个走红的性教育视频叫《你无法戳破你的处女膜》，它是关于处女膜的。
The hymen doesn't completely cover the vagina at all. It doesn't need to be popped. It doesn't need to be broken. The hymen is a very thin--
处女膜根本不会完全覆盖阴道。它不需要被戳破。它不需要被弄破。处女膜是一个非常薄的——
And it was about basic anatomy-- what the hymen is, and also a little bit of cultural analysis about the hymen myth and some of the sexism that drives it.
它是关于基础解剖学的——什么是处女膜，以及一点关于处女膜神话和驱动它的某些性别歧视的文化分析。
The hymen myth?
处女膜神话？
Yeah, that you have to break your hymen when you first have penetrative sex.
是的，就是那种认为你第一次进行插入式性行为时必须弄破处女膜的说法。
So, let's talk for a second about this misconception that the hymen covers the whole vagina and needs to be broken. Not only is it outright false-- wrong! It's also kind of violent. Ah! Big, bad penis needs to come in and pop your hymen and make you bleed and--
所以，我们来谈谈这个误区，即认为处女膜覆盖整个阴道并且需要被弄破。这不仅是完全错误的——不对！而且有点暴力。啊！大坏蛋阴茎需要进来戳破你的处女膜，让你流血，然后——
Laci talks about sex like an enthusiastic nerd-- excited, totally unembarrassed. She started getting hundreds of thousands of views-- millions of views. The videos brought in steady money and opportunities. She went on Dr. Phil. She was the host of MTV's first YouTube series-- it was called Braless. All of this-- this whole sex ed career-- was basically an outgrowth of her childhood, or really a reaction to it.
蕾西谈论性就像一个热情的书呆子——兴奋，完全不尴尬。她的视频获得了数十万的播放量——数百万的播放量。视频带来了稳定的收入和机会。她上了菲尔博士的节目。她是MTV第一个YouTube系列节目的主持人——名叫《不戴胸罩》。所有这些——整个性教育生涯——基本上是她童年的产物，或者确实是对它的一种反抗。
She grew up in a small town near Sacramento, raised within the Mormon church, which she found stifling.
她在萨克拉门托附近的一个小镇长大，在摩门教中被抚养长大，她觉得那里让人窒息。
This is relevant because the Mormon church is strictly anti-masturbation, which absolutely did not stop me from doing it. It just made me feel really bad when I did. In my early teens, I was overcome with shame and guilt and anger-- anger at myself.
这很有相关性，因为摩门教严格反对自慰，但这绝对没能阻止我这样做。它只是让我在做的时候感到非常糟糕。在我的青春期早期，我被羞耻、内疚和愤怒所笼罩——对自己感到愤怒。
Which brings us to the first word that got Laci in trouble. It isn't the kind of word you bleep in a radio story.
这引出了蕾西惹上麻烦的第一个词。它不是你在广播故事中消音的那种词。
Yeah, I made this video called, 50 Reasons Why I'm a Feminist. That's kind of when the storm began, I would say.
是的，我做了这个视频叫《我成为女权主义者的50个理由》。我可以说，那就是风暴开始的时候。
Feminist. She said it on purpose, and she knew it would provoke a reaction online, not just from people who watch her videos, but from people who can't stand feminism-- people who go searching for feminist videos to criticize. She knew she was about to get sucked into an endless cycle of reactions and counter-reactions.
女权主义者。她是故意这么说的，她知道这会在网上引起反应，不仅来自看她视频的人，也来自那些无法忍受女权主义的人——那些专门搜索女权主义视频进行批评的人。她知道自己即将卷入一场无休止的反应和反反应的循环中。
And I waited a long time-- actually, sat on that video. I recorded the video and didn't upload it for nearly six months. I just sat on it and waited, until I felt ready to post it. And I never do that. That's not a common thing for me. I just was a little bit scared of what was about to happen.
我等了很久——实际上，那个视频压了很久。我录了视频，近六个月没上传。我只是把它放在那儿，等着，直到我觉得准备好发布了。我从不那样做。这对我来说不常见。我只是有点害怕接下来会发生什么。
The rumors are true-- what they've been saying about me. I have to come clean. I, Laci Green, am a feminist. What? You're a lesbian now? Man hater? Hairy armpits? Say it ain't so!
传闻是真的——关于他们所说的我的一切。我必须坦白。我，蕾西·格林，是一个女权主义者。什么？你现在是女同性恋了？恨男人的人？多毛的腋下？别这么说！
It covered the basics. Women are always judged on their appearance. Girls are called sluts, while boys are called players. But still, the people who loved this video-- they really loved it. The women's website, Bustle, said that it was, quote, "awesomely on point," and HuffPost wrote, "Laci Green reminds us why we all need to be feminists." But there was also a torrent of abusive messages-- messages that still show up at Laci's inbox every day, telling her that someone's going to kill her or that she should do it herself.
它涵盖了基础知识。女性总是因为外貌而被评判。女孩被称为荡妇，而男孩被称为玩家。但尽管如此，喜欢这个视频的人——他们真的非常喜欢。女性网站Bustle称其为“非常到位”，《赫芬顿邮报》写道：“蕾西·格林提醒了我们为什么我们都需要成为女权主义者。”但同时也涌现了大量的辱骂信息——那些每天仍会出现在蕾西收件箱里的信息，告诉她有人要杀了她，或者说她应该自我了断。
It was immediate-- just this immediate reaction. It started getting tons of response videos from all over the internet, blog posts, tweets. My Twitter timeline became a nightmare of people calling me names and calling me a feminazi and all this stuff. And all these people who were making these reply videos-- collectively, they had a pretty big audience. They would send their audience to my channel.
它是即时的——就是那种即时的反应。它开始收到来自互联网各处的成吨回复视频、博客文章、推文。我的推特时间线变成了一个噩梦，人们叫我各种绰号，叫我“女权纳粹”之类的东西。而所有这些制作回复视频的人——总的来说，他们拥有非常庞大的受众。他们会把他们的受众引向我的频道。
Laci's video was supposed to empower young women, but it also did a pretty good job empowering guys who like to criticize young women-- guys who proudly call themselves anti-feminists. The whole point of being an anti-feminist is to mock and criticize feminism, which means that the anti-feminists on YouTube need to find feminists to mock and criticize.
蕾西的视频本意是赋予年轻女性力量，但它也成功地赋予了那些喜欢批评年轻女性的男性力量——那些自豪地称自己为“反女权主义者”的男性。作为反女权主义者的全部意义就是嘲讽和批评女权主义，这意味着YouTube上的反女权主义者需要找到女权主义者来嘲讽和批评。
I haven't actually watched this video yet, but I know by the title, it's going to be fucking great. Here's Why I'm a Feminist, by Laci Green.
我还没真正看过这个视频，但我通过标题就知道它肯定会棒极了。这是蕾西·格林的《我为什么是女权主义者》。
The rumors are true.
传闻是真的。
Anti-feminists can mean lots of different things. It might refer to someone who obsessively harasses and insults women on the internet, or it might refer to someone who likes to crack jokes about the perceived excesses of feminist discourse. And on the internet, of course, it's not always easy to draw a bright line between harmless jokes and pernicious harassment. This guy, for instance, Sargon of Akkad.
反女权主义者可能意味着很多不同的东西。它可能指的是在互联网上痴迷地骚扰和侮辱女性的人，或者指的是喜欢拿女权主义话语中被认为过激的地方开玩笑的人。当然，在互联网上，并不总是容易在无害的玩笑和恶意骚扰之间画出一条清晰的界线。例如这个人，萨尔贡·阿卡德。
Back to the yucks.
回到笑话上。
He's mainly known for acerbic videos about how liberals are irrational, but he did once tweet, "I wouldn't even rape you," at a female politician he disagreed with. He made a video where he mocked Laci's video, and it got nearly a million views.
他主要以辛辣的视频闻名，内容是关于自由派如何非理性，但他曾经确实向一位他不认同的女政治家发推文说：“我甚至都不会强奸你。”他制作了一个嘲讽蕾西视频的视频，获得了近一百万的播放量。
I think that feminism is both kick ass and super important, and here are a few of my reasons why.
我认为女权主义既牛逼又超级重要，这就是我支持它的几个原因。
Because feminist supremacy would make you a primary beneficiary of all the benefits it would bring to a privileged class? Oh, I'm sure that's not it, Laci. I'm sure it's not.
因为女权主义霸权会让你成为它给特权阶层带来的所有利益的主要受益者？哦，我敢肯定那不是重点，蕾西。我敢肯定不是。
Here's another video by a guy named Chris Ray Gun. He used Laci's picture to illustrate a satirical song.
这是另一个叫克里斯·雷·冈的人做的视频。他用蕾西的照片来演示一首讽刺歌曲。
(SINGING) Women infantilized every day. But not by the men who the feminists blame, but instead by the motto that constantly claims. The patriarchy is raging.
（唱歌）女性每天都被婴儿化。不是被女权主义者责怪的那些男人，而是被不断声称的那句口号。父权制正在肆虐。
Around the same time, Laci started taking a lot of heat from a different group-- the people who were supposed to be on her side. The people at the heart of her fan base-- college kids.
大约在同一时间，蕾西开始受到来自另一群人的猛烈抨击——那些本应站在她一边的人。她粉丝群的核心群体——大学生。
She still remembers the moment when she first came face to face with it. She'd been touring colleges as a speaker. Lots of students knew her from YouTube, so they'd show up to hear her talk about healthy relationships, and they would submit anonymous questions that they were too embarrassed to ask anyone else. So, this was four years ago-- 2014. Laci doesn't even want to mention the college's name.
她仍然记得第一次面对这种情况的时刻。她一直在大学巡回演讲。许多学生在YouTube上认识她，所以他们会来看她谈论健康的关系，并且会提交他们羞于问别人的匿名问题。所以，这是四年前——2014年。蕾西甚至不想提那所大学的名字。
And I walk in, and there's a bunch of students there. And some of the students are clapping and saying, yay, but there's a ton of boos in the audience. And I've never had that happen before.
我走进去，里面有一群学生。有些学生在鼓掌欢呼，但观众席里有大量的嘘声。我以前从未遇到过这种情况。
She was confused. She didn't know why they were mad at her.
她很困惑。她不知道他们为什么生她的气。
I don't know what to do. These are my peers. I'm not that much older than them. I mostly ignored it. I actually couldn't even-- when I was up there, I couldn't even really hear what they were saying. I just knew that they were shouting things while I was talking. It's like, what are you doing? It's never happened to me before. I've never had students just yell. How rude.
我不知道该做什么。这些是我的同龄人。我并不比他们大多少。我大多忽视了它。实际上我甚至无法——当我在台上时，我甚至听不清他们在说什么。我只知道我在说话时他们在喊叫。就像，你们在做什么？这在我身上从没发生过。我从未遇到过学生们只是在那儿吼叫。太无礼了。
She gave her talk, despite the push back. But some of the things she said made it worse. Afterwards, the school newspaper described the scene.
尽管遭到了抵制，她还是完成了演讲。但她所说的一些事情让情况变得更糟了。事后，校报描述了当时的场景。
I'm looking at a picture of you in a plaid, flannel shirt, it looks like. They quote one of the students that was upset, and she says-- this is one of the students speaking, saying, "some of the things that she said," meaning you, "were very alienating to me, at least, and I think that one of them was that she used the homophobic slur, dyke, a couple of times, and not as a self-referential thing. Not as a self-identity, but as a way to describe a party she didn't like. I think I know where she's"--
我正看着一张你穿着格子法兰绒衬衫的照片。他们引用了一位感到愤怒的学生的话，她说——这是其中一位学生在说，称：“她所说的一些事情，意思是说你，对我来说非常疏远，我认为其中之一是她说了几次同性恋歧视性词汇‘女同’（dyke），而且不是作为一种自称。不是作为一种自我认同，而是作为一种描述她不喜欢的人群的方式。我想我知道她在那儿——”
That is not true at all. What the fuck?
那根本不是事实。什么鬼？
And the student said, "I think that she doesn't mean to be homophobic, but that's still a slur, and I still associate it, at least, with homophobia and with violence." So it sounds like you had mentioned in your talk, dyke parties.
那位学生说：“我想她并非故意要歧视同性恋，但这仍然是一个歧视性词汇，我仍然至少把它与同性恋恐惧症和暴力联系在一起。”所以听起来你在演讲中提到了“女同”聚会。
But the parties are called dyke parties.
但那些聚会本身就叫“女同”聚会。
Right.
对。
That was definitely a thing that would happen in San Francisco and at Berkeley, where people would have dyke parties, where only women were invited, and it was just like a thing that happened. What do you want me to say? D-word party?
这绝对是在旧金山和伯克利会发生的事情，人们会举办女同聚会，只邀请女性，这只是发生的一件事而已。你想让我说什么？D字头聚会？
My problem is the way that she framed it as if I was calling people dykes or something. And it's just the deliberate sort of twisting of what you say and what you do all the time, to make it seem like you're just this evil, deep down homophobe who's just-- you're revealing your evil nature when you use various words or whatever and taking things out of context all the time.
我的问题是她将其框定为我好像在叫别人“女同”之类的。这只是为了扭曲你的所作所为，让你看起来像是一个骨子里邪恶、恐同的人，当你使用各种词汇时，你就在揭露你邪恶的本质，或者诸如此类，而且总是断章取义。
Dyke was the second word that got her in trouble. But that isn't even the reason they were upset with her from the moment she got there. That was probably because of the fallout from a third word she'd said, way back in 2009.
“女同”是惹她麻烦的第二个词。但这甚至不是他们从她到达那一刻起就对她不满的原因。那可能是因为她早在2009年说出的第三个词所产生的后果。
I had this video way back in the day where I said the T-word.
我过去有一个视频，我说了T字头词汇。
The T-word. I'm not going to say it, either. But it's spelled T-R-A-N-N-Y. A word for transgender people, widely seen these days as derogatory.
T字头词汇。我也不会说它。但它的拼写是T-R-A-N-N-Y（人妖）。一个针对跨性别者的词，在当今被广泛视为贬义词。
So the short story is, I had made this fan video for Chris Crocker, who is a self-proclaimed T-word. I made a fan video saying I love him, blah, blah, blah. I used the T-word in the video, then later on, a bunch of social justice types dragged it up to prove that I am a evil transphobe.
所以长话短说，我为克里斯·克罗克制作了一个粉丝视频，他自称为T字头人士。我制作了一个粉丝视频说我爱他，等等等等。我在视频中用了那个T字头词汇，后来，一群社会正义人士把它翻出来证明我是一个邪恶的跨性别恐惧者。
Chris Crocker. He's a YouTube personality who went viral back in 2007, when he made a video saying, "leave Britney alone!" Back in 2009, Laci made a video saying that she loved him, and she used the T-word. She thought it was OK because that's a word Chris had used about himself.
克里斯·克罗克。他是YouTube名人，早在2007年就走红了，当时他制作了一个视频说“放过布兰妮吧！”。2009年，蕾西制作了一个视频说她爱他，并用了那个T字头词汇。她认为这没问题，因为那是克里斯曾经用在自己身上的词。
When someone asked Laci about it in 2012, she apologized. She unpublished the video. She said she had learned how harmful the word was, but some people objected that she used the word again in her written apology. And Laci says she was targeted and harassed by people who saw her as a symbol of transphobia.
当有人在2012年问蕾西关于这件事时，她道歉了。她撤下了视频。她说她已经学会了这个词有多么有害，但有些人反对她在书面道歉中再次使用了这个词。蕾西说她成为了那些把她视为跨性别恐惧症象征的人的目标，并受到了骚扰。
It was really, really, really horrible. People came to my house. They took pictures of my door. They took pictures of me while I was in public and sent it to me through my email. It was nuts. That was absolutely insane.
那真的很恐怖，真的。人们来到我家。他们拍了我的门。当我在公共场合时，他们拍了我并把照片发到我的电子邮件里。太疯狂了。那绝对是疯了。
That's what kick-started the perception that Laci was transphobic and problematic, and that perception followed her to the stage of that college. Laci was stumbling across all these words you can't say, and of course, the modern archetype for what's supposed to happen with these words is the N-word.
这就是触发了蕾西是跨性别恐惧症患者且有问题这种认知的开始，这种认知一直跟随她到那所大学的舞台上。蕾西在所有这些不能说的词汇上绊倒了，当然，关于这些词汇应该发生什么的现代原型是N字头词汇。
Lots of people feel like the N-word is so ugly, so damaging, so scary, that non-black people aren't allowed to say it, ever. It doesn't matter if they're quoting a song. It doesn't matter if they're reading from an antebellum novel. It doesn't matter the context. They can't say it. Then the question is, how many other words are like the N-word? How many other words can't be said?
很多人觉得N字头词汇太丑陋，太具破坏性，太可怕了，以至于非黑人永远不允许说它。引用歌词也没关系。引用战前小说也没关系。上下文也不重要。他们就是不能说。那么问题是，还有多少词像N字头词汇一样？有多少其他词是不能说的？
That was kind of when I started to notice the more social justice warrior side of things.
那时候我开始注意到更偏向社会正义斗士的一面了。
OK, so just in case you haven't heard this one, social justice warrior-- an insult that can be thrown at anyone who speaks up against racism, sexism, transphobia, homophobia, all the other -isms and phobias.
好的，为了防备你还没听说过这个词，“社会正义斗士”——这是一个可以被扔向任何敢于反对种族主义、性别歧视、跨性别恐惧症、同性恋恐惧症以及所有其他“主义”和“恐惧症”的人的侮辱性词汇。
Students felt like it was OK to be rude, to call names, to degrade and disrespect people because they weren't woke enough or something. This idea that the words themselves have more meaning than the context that they're in.
学生们觉得对人无礼、起绰号、贬低和不尊重别人是可以的，因为他们不够“觉醒”（woke）什么的。这种观点认为词汇本身的意义比它们所处的语境更重要。
There were other words she couldn't say-- words that were more fundamental to the kinds of videos she made.
还有其他她不能说的词——那些对她制作的视频类型更基础的词。
People got mad when I would say male or female in a video to refer to anatomical stuff, like female orgasm or male sexuality or whatever. Yeah, people said, can you not say male or female?
当我试图在视频中使用“男性”或“女性”来指代解剖学相关内容，比如女性性高潮或男性性欲之类的时，人们会生气。是的，人们说，你不能说男性或女性吗？
That's the thing. She makes sex ed videos, so she talks all the time about genitals, about reproductive health, about sex. There's basically no way for her to avoid these words without making some pretty fundamental changes to the way she talks, like how do you talk about someone who's intersex? Born with sex organs or traits that don't fit traditional definitions of female or male?
这就是问题所在。她制作性教育视频，所以她一直在谈论生殖器、生殖健康、性。基本上没有办法让她在不大幅改变她谈话方式的情况下避开这些词，比如你如何谈论一个双性人？生来就具有不符合女性或男性传统定义的性器官或特征的人？
Yeah, I made a video about intersex conditions. And in the video, I talked about sex development in the womb and sex differentiation and how we become male and female, and they're somewhere in between. And people didn't like that I used the terms male and female, but literally, how do you explain intersex without male or female? I've thought about it so many times. I don't even know. You have to use anatomical terms.
是的，我制作了一个关于双性人状况的视频。在视频中，我谈到了子宫内的性发育和性分化，以及我们如何变成男性和女性，它们介于两者之间。人们不喜欢我使用“男性”和“女性”这两个词，但说真的，如果没有“男性”或“女性”，你如何解释双性人？我思考过很多次。我甚至不知道。你必须使用解剖学词汇。
And how do you talk about sex and anatomy without saying male and female?
而且你怎么能在不说男性和女性的情况下谈论性和解剖学呢？
Well, I start using the terms vagina-owner and penis-owner. I was trying to be creative. I want to address the genitals. If you have a penis, is it applicable? And that's kind of the route that I've taken since.
嗯，我开始使用“阴道拥有者”和“阴茎拥有者”这两个词。我试图有创意一点。我想指代生殖器。如果你有阴茎，它适用吗？这就是我此后采用的路径。
Did you get positive feedback when you started talking about penis-havers and vagina-havers, as opposed to males and females?
当你开始谈论“阴茎拥有者”和“阴道拥有者”，而不是“男性”和“女性”时，你得到的是正面反馈吗？
No. I mean, yes. But also no. Some people liked it. I'd say more people didn't like it. They're like, why are you calling me a vagina-owner? And I'm like, ugh.
不。我是说，有。但也有没有。有些人喜欢它。我会说更多的人不喜欢它。他们就像，你为什么要叫我“阴道拥有者”？我就觉得，呃。
So, if this is new to you, and you're wondering why some people want to avoid the words male and female, the idea is this. When you call a penis a male sex organ, you're kind of implying that having a penis makes you a man, and that's not true for everyone. You're leaving out some transgender people, for instance. None of this satisfied the growing number of people who thought Laci was totally problematic.
所以，如果这对你来说是新鲜事，你很好奇为什么有些人想避开“男性”和“女性”这两个词，其核心理念是这样的。当你称阴茎为男性性器官时，你是在暗示拥有阴茎就让你成为了男人，而这对每个人来说都不一定是真的。例如，你忽略了一些跨性别者。这一切都无法满足那些认为蕾西完全有问题的日益增多的人。
On Tumblr, someone put together a list. It was called "Masterpost-- Why Laci Green Sucks." It had 93 entries, accusing her of hypocrisy, ignorance, insensitivity. It explained why her commentary had been hurtful, not just to trans people, but to women, people suffering from mental illness, Muslims, millennials, vegans of color. When she first started making videos, it felt like freedom, and now it felt like the opposite.
在Tumblr上，有人整理了一份清单。它叫“主贴——为什么蕾西·格林很烂”。它有93条条目，指责她虚伪、无知、不敏感。它解释了为什么她的评论具有伤害性，不仅是对跨性别者，还有对女性、精神疾病患者、穆斯林、千禧一代、有色人种纯素食者。当她刚开始制作视频时，感觉就像自由，而现在感觉恰恰相反。
It started to feel like being back in Mormonism. You've got this sort of doctrine-- the social justice doctrine that you hold on to. The intention is good-- to make us better people, to do better by each other, to become more moral. They're both moral systems, and they operate in similar ways. Using shaming when you get out of line.
它开始感觉就像回到了摩门教。你拥有一种教条——你所坚持的社会正义教条。初衷是好的——让我们成为更好的人，互相善待，变得更有道德。它们都是道德体系，并且以类似的方式运作。当你脱离轨道时使用羞辱。
There's just sort of this feeling of repression on your chest, where you just can't speak freely or be freely in the world. And it felt exactly the same to me, like I was policing my own thoughts and words. I felt like a bad person all the time.
心中有一种压抑感，你只是不能自由地说话或自由地活在世界上。对我来说感觉完全一样，就像我在监视自己的思想和言论。我一直觉得自己是一个坏人。
After being mocked by the anti-feminists and then being assailed by the social justice crowd, she scaled up. She started attracting the hostility of a much bigger, louder group-- Trump supporters.
在受到反女权主义者的嘲讽，然后又遭到社会正义群体的抨击后，她升级了。她开始吸引了一个更大、更嘈杂的群体的敌意——特朗普的支持者。
Well, I tweeted that night of the election. I said, "fuck white America," when Trump won.
嗯，我在选举那晚发了推特。当特朗普赢了之后，我说：“去他的美国白人。”
The tweet went viral. Conservatives passed it around to make fun of liberals who were losing their mind over Trump. Here's what her original tweet actually said. "We are now under total Republican rule. Textbook fascism. Fuck you, white America. Fuck you, you racist, misogynist pieces of shit. Good night."
那条推文疯传。保守派们到处转发它，以此取笑那些因为特朗普而失去理智的自由派。她最初的推文其实是这么说的：“我们现在处于共和党的完全统治之下。教科书式的法西斯主义。去你的，美国白人。去你的，你们这群种族主义、厌女症的混蛋。晚安。”
Oopsie.
哎呀。
And some people noticed that the day before, or on election day or the day before, you had tweeted, "regardless of the outcome, we are clearly a deeply divided and broken country. So much work ahead to mend, heal, and restore the U in USA."
有些人注意到，前一天，或者选举当天或前一天，你曾发推文说：“无论结果如何，我们显然是一个深度分裂和破碎的国家。还有很多工作要做，以弥补、治愈和修复美国。”
And some people noticed that there had been a change in tone and thought that that was funny or revealing. And one person actually wrote to you on Twitter, "Hey Laci, do you, like, not see how you're acting like the very thing you claim to be opposed to?" Do you remember who wrote that tweet?
有些人注意到语气发生了变化，认为这很可笑或很能说明问题。其中一个人甚至在推特上写道：“嘿，蕾西，你难道没看出来你的行为和你声称反对的东西一模一样吗？”你还记得是谁写的吗？
No.
不记得。
It was a guy who is known as Chris Ray Gun online.
那是一个在网上被称为克里斯·雷·冈的家伙。
I knew you were going to zing with that. I knew it was coming.
我就知道你要用那个来讽刺我。我知道它会来的。
Chris Ray Gun-- an anti-feminist with a YouTube channel. A guy who liked to make fun of people like Laci. A guy who liked to make fun of Laci herself. Chris is the one who made up that song.
克里斯·雷·冈——一个拥有YouTube频道的反女权主义者。一个喜欢拿像蕾西这样的人开玩笑的家伙。一个喜欢拿蕾西本人开玩笑的家伙。克里斯就是那个制作了那首歌的人。
(SINGING) The patriarchy is raging.
（唱歌）父权制正在肆虐。
Laci is giggling because Chris Ray Gun, the YouTubing anti-feminist, is now her boyfriend, which is a pretty wild twist in Laci Green's story, considering the trolling that she went through from him and from his friends. And to explain it, we have to back up. Laci had booked a series of talks on college campuses in the weeks after the election.
蕾西在咯咯笑，因为克里斯·雷·冈，那个YouTube反女权主义者，现在是她的男朋友，这对蕾西·格林的故事来说是一个相当疯狂的转折，考虑到她从他以及他的朋友那里经历的网暴。为了解释这一点，我们必须倒退。在选举后的几周里，蕾西预订了一系列在大学校园的演讲。
As soon as I came out on stage, people started screaming, fuck you, cunt. Fuck you, bitch. You lost. Trump, Trump Trump. Started throwing pencils and paper and whatever crap had in their backpack at me. I was really scared. I was scared that one of these students was going to rush the stage and hurt me. That's all I could think about. I can't do this. My mind's not in this place. It's not worth it.
我一上台，人们就开始尖叫，去你的，骚货。去你的，荡妇。你输了。特朗普，特朗普，特朗普。开始把铅笔、纸和背包里有的垃圾往我身上扔。我真的被吓坏了。我害怕这些学生中的某一个会冲上舞台伤害我。我能想到的只有这些。我做不到。我的心不在这儿。这不值得。
Online, the vitriol against her and her feminist allies got 10 times worse after the election. And after a few months of that, Laci decided she'd had enough of everyone ranting at each other, especially ranting at her. She'd try something different.
在网上，选举后针对她和她的女权主义盟友的尖刻言论变本加厉了。几个月后，蕾西决定她受够了每个人互相咆哮，尤其是对她咆哮。她想尝试一些不同的东西。
She'd reach out directly to one of the antagonists, Blaire White. Now, Blaire is a conservative who's also a trans woman, and she'd become an unlikely hero to anti-feminists. Blaire had been making nasty videos about one of Laci's friends, so Laci began a careful approach to Blaire.
她会直接联系其中一个对手，布莱尔·怀特。布莱尔是一位保守派，同时也是一位跨性别女性，她成为了反女权主义者中意想不到的英雄。布莱尔一直在制作关于蕾西的一位朋友的恶毒视频，所以蕾西开始谨慎地接近布莱尔。
First, she followed her on Twitter. Blaire noticed, and she tweeted, "Laci Green just followed me. Was that an accident, girl? lol." "Ha ha, nope. Been watching your vids and appreciate your perspective. Sometimes, I agree. Sometimes, I'm confused. Want to chat?" Nerd face emoji. "Yes, honey. Let's talk."
首先，她在推特上关注了她。布莱尔注意到了，发推文说：“蕾西·格林刚关注了我。那是意外吗，姑娘？哈哈哈。”“哈哈，不。我一直在看你的视频，很欣赏你的观点。有时，我同意。有时，我很困惑。想聊聊吗？”书呆子表情符号。“是的，亲爱的。我们谈谈。”
The people on Twitter couldn't decide whether this was a good idea. More than one of Blaire's followers responded with an image of Admiral Ackbar from Return of the Jedi saying, "It's a trap!" In fact, when Laci and Blaire finally streamed their 2 and 1/2 hour long video chat, it was pretty civilized.
推特上的人们无法决定这是一个好主意。布莱尔的粉丝中不止一个人用《星球大战：绝地归来》中阿克巴上将的图片回应说：“这是个陷阱！”事实上，当蕾西和布莱尔最终直播了她们长达2个半小时的视频聊天时，场面相当文明。
Do these opinions and feelings need to be expressed in such a mean, cruel way?
这些观点和感受需要以这种刻薄、残酷的方式表达出来吗？
Yeah, I mean--
是啊，我的意思是——
I don't think it does.
我不认为需要。
Yeah, like I said, there are certain content creators where their MO is just to destroy a person and others who--
对，就像我说的，有些内容创作者他们的作风就是摧毁一个人，而其他人——
I knew when I was talking to Blaire that I was basically speaking to that entire community, because they were all watching.
我在和布莱尔说话时就知道，我基本上是在和整个群体对话，因为他们都在看着。
Laci started hearing from other people in the anti-feminist world. They wanted to talk, too.
蕾西开始收到反女权主义世界其他人的来信。他们也想谈谈。
Very, very eager to have these conversations, and not even publicly-- wanted to just sit down and have lunch at Chipotle, have a Skype on a Friday night when we're all just bumming around.
非常、非常渴望进行这些对话，甚至不是公开的——只是想坐下来在Chipotle吃顿午餐，在周五晚上我们都在闲逛时来一次Skype通话。
Talking to a celebrity YouTube feminist like Laci was a good way to get viewers. The idea was that Laci was making friends with her enemies-- people from the other tribe. In this world of YouTubers, it was a major plot development. Everyone wanted to see what would happen next. Was Laci undergoing some kind of conversion? Was she switching teams?
与蕾西这样的YouTube名人女权主义者交谈是获得观众的好方法。这个想法是蕾西正在和她的敌人交朋友——来自另一个部落的人。在YouTube这个世界里，这是一个重大的剧情发展。每个人都想看看接下来会发生什么。蕾西是在进行某种转变吗？她在换阵营吗？
Talked to Andy Warski.
和安迪·沃斯基谈过。
He's a hyper-aggressive YouTuber. He once said that social justice warriors should be shot-- metaphorically, he added, for legal reasons.
他是一个极具侵略性的YouTube用户。他曾经说社会正义斗士应该被枪毙——比喻意义上的，他补充说，出于法律原因。
Yeah, I talked to Sargon.
是的，我和萨尔贡谈过。
That's the guy who got almost a million hits on his video making fun of Laci's feminism video.
就是那个在嘲讽蕾西女权主义视频中获得近一百万播放量的家伙。
I talked to Bunty King, who is now one of my best friends.
我和邦蒂·王谈过，他现在是我最好的朋友之一。
He's a Canadian guy of Indian descent who loves to mock social justice warriors.
他是一位印裔加拿大人，喜欢嘲讽社会正义斗士。
All of them. I've had conversations in some capacity with all of them.
他们所有人。我与他们每个人都以某种身份进行过交谈。
Take 45. Take 41. Take 97. Take fuck my ass. You've got a friend in me! Hey, everybody. Welcome back to the Ray Gun Recap. Chris Ray Gun here, coming at you live from an unyielding whirlwind of physically and emotionally crippling stress.
第45条，第41条，第97条，去你的屁股。你有个朋友在身边！嘿，大家好。欢迎回到“雷·冈简报”。我是克里斯·雷·冈，正在一场无法阻挡、生理和心理上都令人崩溃的压力旋风中直播。
OK, so this is Chris Ray Gun, the patriarchy is raging guy. After Laci made a video about all these conversations, he made a video about her video, using her video in his video. That's how this world works.
好吧，这就是克里斯·雷·冈，那个唱“父权制正在肆虐”的家伙。在蕾西制作了一个关于所有这些对话的视频后，他制作了一个关于她视频的视频，在他的视频中使用了她的视频。这个世界就是这样运作的。
People have been pretty kind to me, and I'll be honest. I didn't really expect that. No judgment, no vitriol. I even feel like I have a really good connection with a couple of new friends-- couple of new friends-- couple of new friends.
人们对我相当友善，老实说。我真的没想到。没有评判，没有尖刻。我甚至觉得我和几个新朋友——几个新朋友——几个新朋友——之间建立了非常好的联系。
At this point, the screen goes black and white, and we see a close-up of Chris popping his collar in slow motion.
此时，屏幕变成黑白，我们看到克里斯慢动作竖起领子的特写。
Yeah, that's right, guys. That's the main part of the video that a lot of social justice types seem to have a problem with. And there is certainly more to that video than just that, but this appears to be the main point of contention. It's essentially just a video where Laci Green says, hey, you know, not all anti-SJW YouTubers are sub-human, Nazi pieces of filth, and I'm actually open to having a dialogue with them.
是的，没错，伙计们。这就是很多社会正义类型的人似乎觉得有问题的视频的主要部分。那个视频的内容远不止于此，但这似乎是争论的焦点。本质上，这是一个蕾西·格林说的视频，嘿，你知道，并非所有反SJW（反社会正义斗士）的YouTube用户都是次人类、纳粹混蛋，我实际上愿意和他们进行对话。
Then he makes fun of some of the feminist men who criticized Laci, but there's also a moment of journalistic disclosure.
然后他拿一些批评蕾西的女权主义男性开玩笑，但也有一个新闻披露的时刻。
Now, with all that said, what do I think about this whole Laci Green thing? First, I should let all you guys know that I've actually become pretty good friends with Laci Green. We've been hanging out quite a bit, recently. So, that is a thing that people should be aware of-- ethical standards and all that. I'm letting you guys know that there is a bit of a conflict of interest here. But here's what I really think.
现在，话虽如此，我怎么看这整个蕾西·格林的事情？首先，我应该让你们所有人知道，我实际上已经成为了蕾西·格林相当不错的朋友。我们最近经常在一起玩。所以，这是一件人们应该意识到的事情——职业道德什么的。我让你们知道这里有一点利益冲突。但这就是我的真实想法。
He just cracks me up. He's so funny, and he's such a sweetie. He really is. He's got the biggest heart. You might not know it from his YouTube channel.
他让我笑得前仰后合。他太风趣了，他是个甜心。他真是。他有一颗最宽广的心。你可能从他的YouTube频道看不出来。
Chris and Laci had lunch at Chipotle for four hours, then they kept hanging out, and Laci made a decision. She wouldn't Google him. She knew he was part of the anti-feminist tribe, more or less. But that was about it.
克里斯和蕾西在Chipotle吃了一顿四个小时的午餐，然后他们继续在一起玩，蕾西做了一个决定。她不会去搜索他。她知道他或多或少是反女权主义部落的一部分。但仅此而已。
After all those years of straining to take everyone seriously, she liked the fact that he didn't even try. To him and to many anti-feminists, it was all a big game-- people trolling each other, making dumb jokes, sometimes arguing. He didn't take it so personally. And that's why she liked him. Also, they like each other's company.
在多年努力认真对待每个人之后，她喜欢他不尝试那么做的事实。对他和许多反女权主义者来说，这都是一场大游戏——人们互相网暴，开愚蠢的玩笑，有时争论。他没有那么往心里去。这就是为什么她喜欢他。此外，他们喜欢彼此的陪伴。
Some debates over dinner or breakfast.
晚餐或早餐时的一些辩论。
And sometimes they talk about the same things they talk about in their videos.
有时他们谈论他们在视频中谈论的同样的事情。
We have talked a lot about what rape culture is, the extent to which the United States is a rape culture. He actually does see it pretty much the same way as I do, and once we change the language, we talk about it as not rape culture, but as coercion culture. The ways that our--
我们讨论了很多关于什么是强奸文化，美国在多大程度上是强奸文化。他实际上和我看法基本一致，一旦我们改变语言，我们把它谈论为不是强奸文化，而是强迫文化。我们的方式——
And of course, once people found out she was dating Chris Ray Gun, it was kind of a big deal. The website, Vox, published a story that accused Laci of dating an alt-right troll. The story quoted an activist on Twitter who had written, "don't date alt right. Don't date white supremacists." And it quoted a popular Facebook post that accused Laci of turning her back on people of color.
当然，一旦人们发现她正在和克里斯·雷·冈约会，这算是一件大事。Vox网站发表了一篇文章，指责蕾西约会一个右翼网络恶霸（alt-right troll）。文章引用了一位推特上的激进分子的话：“不要约会极右翼。不要约会白人至上主义者。”它引用了一个流行的脸书帖子，指责蕾西背弃了有色人种。
It should be said that it's kind of strange to describe Chris Ray Gun as a white supremacist or a member of the alt-right. He's more like a sarcastic Puerto Rican guy from the Bronx who loves video games and thinks the social justice movement is ridiculous. More and more, Laci found herself hanging out with Chris and his friends, the anti-feminists. This made some feminist YouTubers really upset.
应该说，把克里斯·雷·冈描述为白人至上主义者或极右翼成员有点奇怪。他更像是一个来自布朗克斯、喜欢电子游戏、认为社会正义运动很荒谬的讽刺性波多黎各小伙。蕾西发现自己越来越多地和克里斯以及他的朋友——那些反女权主义者待在一起。这让一些女权主义YouTube博主非常生气。
If you're happy to associate with people who've sent their mob of shit heads toward me, then I just don't care about you.
如果你乐于结交那些把你那群混蛋派向我的人，那我就不在乎你了。
Like Riley J. Dennis, the old friend of Laci's, who had been targeted by Blaire White on YouTube.
比如莱利·J·丹尼斯，蕾西的老朋友，曾被布莱尔·怀特在YouTube上针对过。
Maybe it's a this is our group and this is your group thing. But that group has done so many terrible things to me that even if you haven't directly done it, if you're still buddy-buddy with all these people, that hurts. That's like you're basically cosigning it.
也许这是一个“这是我们的团队，这是你的团队”的问题。但那个团队对我做了那么多糟糕的事情，即使你没有直接做，如果你仍然和所有这些人称兄道弟，那会很受伤。这就像你基本上在背书。
Some people were saying that maybe Laci had never been a real feminist.
有些人说也许蕾西从未成为一个真正的女权主义者。
This seems to have had much more fallout for you than it has for him.
这件事对你来说似乎比对他造成了更多的后果。
Yeah, it definitely had more fallout for me.
是的，它绝对对我造成了更多的后果。
It kind of feels like you're the one who paid the price for this.
感觉你似乎是为这件事付出代价的人。
Yes. That is definitely true, because none of his followers care. They didn't turn around and be like, Chris Ray Gun is dating a feminazi, and she's just like this evil, horrible, man hater, baby killer. That just didn't happen. They just did not respond in that way, at all.
是的。那绝对是真的，因为他的追随者根本不在乎。他们没有回头说，看，克里斯·雷·冈在约会一个“女权纳粹”，她就像那个邪恶、恐怖、恨男人的人、杀婴者。那根本没有发生。他们根本没有以那种方式做出反应。
I feel like the feminist side of things is just much more negative and eager to bring people down. And that was my perceived tribe, so of course it makes sense that I paid the bigger price for it. And that's one of the things that's bothered me all along, is this sort of gleeful willingness to just try to destroy people.
我觉得女权主义那一面更消极，更渴望把人打倒。那是被我视为的部落，所以当然有道理，我为它付出了更大的代价。这就是一直困扰我的一点，那种幸灾乐祸地试图摧毁他人的意愿。
But you do still identify as a feminist.
但你仍然认同自己是女权主义者。
Yeah. I do feel sort of squished in between these two rocks that are just getting closer and closer. I don't always know how to handle it-- what to do.
是的。我确实觉得自己被夹在这两块正越来越靠近的岩石之间。我并不总是知道如何处理它——该做什么。
In the last year, Laci hasn't posted many videos, and the ones she makes now don't have that same bubbly confidence and clarity. Lately, she presents an issue, like whether toxic masculinity exists or whether it's OK for little boys to be drag queens, and tries to look at it from different angles. She doesn't sound as if she's teaching-- more like she's trying to translate between two groups that don't talk to each other.
在过去的一年里，蕾西没发多少视频，她现在制作的视频也没有了那种同样的冒泡泡的自信和清晰。最近，她提出一个议题，比如有害的男性气概是否存在，或者小男孩成为变装皇后是否没问题，并试图从不同的角度来看待它。她听起来不像是在教导——更像是试图在两个互不交谈的群体之间进行翻译。
This term, toxic masculinity, sounds like you're saying masculinity is toxic. And I think that this is a bigger problem in social justice land. A lot of the language that is used to communicate sounds kind of shamey. Personally, I don't care if we call it--
这个词，“有害的男性气概”，听起来像是在说男性气概是有害的。我认为这是社会正义领域的一个更大的问题。许多用于交流的语言听起来有点羞辱感。就我个人而言，我不在乎我们叫它——
Here's the thing about words you can't say. You can say them, if you want. It's just that there are consequences-- consequences you might not be able to predict. Like, Laci said feminist, and that set off a chain of events that ended with her dating an anti-feminist and leaving some of her feminist allies behind.
关于不能说的词，这就是问题所在。你想说就可以说。只是会有后果——你可能无法预料的后果。就像，蕾西说了“女权主义者”，那触发了一系列连锁事件，以她和一个反女权主义者约会并抛弃了一些女权主义盟友而告终。
Kelefa Sanneh is a staff writer at The New Yorker magazine. Coming up, you shouldn't bring a toy to a gun fight, especially a gun fight in the state legislature. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
凯勒法·萨内是《纽约客》杂志的专职撰稿人。接下来，你不应该带玩具去参加枪战，尤其是在州议会里的枪战。芝加哥公共广播电台将在节目继续后为您带来。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Words You Can't Say." Stories of people saying the wrong thing and accidentally picking a fight with the very people they thought they agreed with. We've arrived at Act 2 of our program, "Trigger Warning." So in this story, a politician uses a word that she loves-- a word her constituents love, in fact, and it backfires. Dana Chivvis tells what happened.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题，“不能说的词”。人们说错话，不小心和他们自以为志同道合的人吵架的故事。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕，“触发警告”。在这个故事里，一位政治家使用了一个她热爱的词——事实上，她的选民也很热爱这个词，但它适得其反了。达娜·奇维斯来讲述发生了什么。
Dodie Horton is in her first term as a state representative in Louisiana, and last year, she made kind of a rookie mistake. She's a Republican who describes herself this way.
多迪·霍顿是路易斯安那州的一名州众议员，处于第一个任期，去年，她犯了一个新手错误。她是一位这样描述自己的共和党人。
I'm just a regular Joe representing regular people like me.
我只是一个代表像我这样的普通人的普通乔。
Dodie's version of regular Joe is pretty far to the right. She's pro-life, pro-gun, voted for a bill to prohibit the removal of Confederate statues in Louisiana. She supports a travel ban, still thinks Barack Obama was born in Kenya, and after Donald Trump was elected President, she felt like--
多迪的“普通乔”版本相当右翼。她反堕胎、拥枪、投票支持一项禁止拆除路易斯安那州邦联雕像的法案。她支持旅行禁令，仍然认为贝拉克·奥巴马出生在肯尼亚，在唐纳德·特朗普当选总统后，她感觉——
America's-- it's rejuvenated again. I saw that in my own district. I see that when I go to the capitol. The excitement of being an American again, he has brought. God had mercy on us. He had mercy on our country because we were headed straight into socialism.
美国——它又恢复活力了。我在我自己的选区看到了。当我去国会大厦时我看到了。他带来的那种作为美国人的兴奋感。上帝怜悯我们。他怜悯了我们的国家，因为我们正径直走向社会主义。
But last spring, something happened that she never expected-- she got beat up for not being conservative enough. It all started at a school in Bossier Parish. They call counties parishes in Louisiana. Bossier Parish is the area that Dodie represents, and back in March, 2016, a high school student was caught with a handgun at a school there.
但去年春天，发生了一件她从未预料到的事情——她因为不够保守而受到了抨击。一切始于博西尔教区的一所学校。他们在路易斯安那州把县称为教区（parish）。博西尔教区是多迪代表的地区，早在2016年3月，一名高中生在那里被发现携带手枪。
No one was shot, but word went around there were other guns at the school. The Sheriff's department, the local police department, and the fire department all showed up. They put the school on lock down, brought in gun sniffing dogs, and searched some of the students. They even flew a drone over the roof to see if anyone had tossed a gun up there, and they did find another gun in a trash can.
没有人被枪击，但传言说学校里还有其他枪支。警长部门、当地警察局和消防部门都赶到了。他们封锁了学校，带进了嗅探犬，并搜查了一些学生。他们甚至让一架无人机飞过屋顶，看看是否有人把枪扔在那儿，他们确实在一个垃圾桶里发现了另一把枪。
When Sheriff Julian Whittington arrived at the scene, he asked one of his deputies to show him the two guns they'd found. They were locked in the deputy's squad car. The sheriff studied them closely. There was something weird about them. Here's Sheriff Whittington.
当朱利安·惠廷顿警长到达现场时，他让一名副警长把他们发现的两把枪拿给他看。它们被锁在副警长的警车里。警长仔细研究了它们。它们有点古怪。这是惠廷顿警长。
Well, I went and got my deputy that had secured it in his vehicle, and I said, I thought you told me both of these were real. And he said, well, they are. I said, no, they're not. Let's look at them closely, here.
嗯，我去找了那个把枪固定在他车里的副警长，我说，我以为你告诉过我这两把都是真的。他说，嗯，它们是。我说，不，它们不是。我们仔细看看。
As it turned out, one of the two guns wasn't real. It was an imitation of a real gun. But the imitation was so good, the deputies hadn't noticed it was fake. It even fooled the Sheriff, at first.
结果证明，其中一把枪不是真的。它是一把真枪的仿制品。但那个仿制品太像了，副警长都没注意到它是假的。起初，它甚至骗过了警长。
I'm telling you, I've handled guns all my life and have a bunch of them, and these things are so real, you literally cannot tell the difference until you literally try to find the clip and what caliber weapon it is. That's how real they are.
我告诉你，我这辈子一直都在玩枪，有一堆枪，这些东西太真实了，你简直无法分辨区别，除非你真地试图找弹夹和确定它是口径武器。它们就是那么真实。
So even holding the fake one in your hand, it has the weight and sort of the metal feel of a real gun?
所以即使把假枪拿在手里，它也有真枪的重量和那种金属质感吗？
After about three or four minutes of holding it and turning it over and looking, you finally determine for certain that it's not a real weapon. That's how real they look.
在大约三四分钟的握持、翻转和观察之后，你最终确定它绝对不是一个真正的武器。它们看起来就是那么真实。
Oh my God. It takes you three or four minutes?
天哪。你花了三四分钟？
It does.
是的。
Wow.
哇。
What if that weapon were in a kid's hand, pointing at you? You don't have three or four minutes.
如果那个武器在一个孩子手里，指着你呢？你可没有三四分钟。
Meaning the cop will shoot whoever is pointing that fake gun at them, even if that person is a kid. And I should pause for a minute to explain something I hadn't truly understood before reporting this story. These fake guns the Sheriff is worried about-- they're not colorful, plastic guns like a Nerf gun or a Super Soaker, or even one of those plastic cap guns that make a loud bang. Those are what I would call toy guns.
这意味着警察会射击任何用假枪指着他们的人，即使那个人是个孩子。我应该停下来解释一下我在此之前没有真正理解的事情。警长担心的这些假枪——它们不是像NERF玩具枪或水枪那样五颜六色的塑料枪，甚至也不是那种发出响声的塑料帽枪。那些是我所说的玩具枪。
These fake guns, like the one the Sheriff's deputy thought was real-- these are basically guns, except they don't use gunpowder to shoot a bullet. I'm sure lots of people are familiar with them-- BB guns and these other ones called Airsoft guns. You can buy them at Walmart and at sporting goods stores. Actually, you can buy them on Amazon. You can buy replicas of AK-47s and M16s on Amazon. The M16s will run you about $30.
这些假枪，像警长副手以为是真的那样的——它们基本上就是枪，除了它们不使用火药发射子弹。我相信很多人对它们很熟悉——BB枪和被称为空气枪（Airsoft）的其他枪。你可以在沃尔玛和体育用品商店买到它们。实际上，你可以在亚马逊上买到它们。你可以在亚马逊上买到AK-47和M16的仿制品。M16大约要30美元。
Some of them use compressed air to shoot plastic or metal BBs. They fire at a lower velocity than real guns, so they're not as dangerous. But you can still get really hurt if you get shot by them. The ones that shoot metal BBs can even kill a person. They're so close to the real thing, the police use them in training. But because they don't use gunpowder, fake guns aren't subject to federal firearm laws and regulations. This incident at the high school rattled the sheriff. He and his deputies weren't sure what they could do to punish a kid who brought a fake gun to school.
它们中的一些使用压缩空气发射塑料或金属弹丸。它们发射的速度比真枪低，所以它们没有那么危险。但如果你被它们射中仍然会受到严重伤害。那些发射金属弹丸的枪甚至可以杀人。它们非常接近实物，警察在训练中使用它们。但因为它们不使用火药，假枪不受联邦枪支法律和法规的约束。学校里发生的这一事件让警长感到震惊。他和他的手下不确定他们能对一个带假枪到学校的孩子做什么。
It was actually the next morning. My guys were talking to me about-- Sheriff, we don't really have a-- we're going to charge him with-- I forget what all. Disturbing the peace, maybe. But they said, since the gun is not real, we can't charge him with having a weapon on campus. I said, what? And so that's when we decided we need to clear this up.
实际上是第二天早上。我的手下在跟我谈论——警长，我们真的没有——我们要指控他什么？扰乱治安，也许。但他们说，因为这把枪不是真的，我们不能指控他携带武器进入校园。我说，什么？所以我们决定我们需要澄清这一点。
Oh, wow. I see the difference now. I don't think I'd appreciated that before. The thing is acting as a weapon, but you can't charge it as a weapon.
哦，哇。我现在看出区别了。我觉得我以前没意识到这一点。这东西像武器一样运作，但你不能以武器罪起诉它。
No, since it's not a real weapon under the current state law, we couldn't charge him with having a weapon on campus.
不，因为它在现行州法律下不是真正的武器，我们不能指控他携带武器进入校园。
It's already illegal to carry a real gun on school campuses in Louisiana. Sheriff Whittington just thought you also shouldn't be able to carry something that looks exactly like a real gun into a school. He's aware of all the news stories about kids with fake guns getting shot by cops.
在路易斯安那州，在学校校园携带真枪已经是非法的了。惠廷顿警长只是认为你不应该能携带看起来和真枪一模一样的东西进入学校。他知道所有关于拿着假枪的孩子被警察射杀的新闻报道。
In California last May, it was a 15-year-old. In Arkansas, a 16-year-old in July. In the last three years, at least 113 people were killed by cops while holding fake weapons, according to data collected by the Washington Post. With all that in mind, the sheriff asked Dodie to sponsor a bill.
在加利福尼亚，去年五月，是一个15岁的孩子。在阿肯色州，七月是一个16岁的孩子。据《华盛顿邮报》收集的数据，在过去三年中，至少有113人在拿着假武器时被警察击毙。考虑到这一点，警长请多迪发起一项法案。
What were you thinking when he's telling you the story about this incident at the high school?
当他向你讲述学校里发生的这起事件时，你在想什么？
Well, I am a gun enthusiast. I support all of our constitutional rights, and we are a huge Second Amendment right district and state, and I'm always packing. Always.
嗯，我是一个枪支发烧友。我支持我们所有的宪法权利，我们是一个巨大的第二修正案权利地区和州，我总是随身带着。总是。
Are you packing right now?
你现在带着吗？
Absolutely.
绝对。
Can I see it?
我能看看吗？
Well, yes.
嗯，可以。
And you just keep it by your desk?
你就把它放在你的书桌旁边？
It's always in my purse.
它一直在我包里。
Oh, you just keep it in your purse. Oh, OK. Look at that.
哦，你把它放在你的包里。哦，好。看看那个。
Yes, that's it.
是的，就是它。
What kind of gun is it?
这是什么枪？
It is a Glock, and what it is-- it's a 9 millimeter. Smaller and easier for me to carry, but just as deadly as if it was a bigger gun.
它是格洛克，它是——它是9毫米的。更小，更容易携带，但就像是一把大枪一样致命。
I see.
我明白了。
But I like it because it fits easily in my purse that I bought because I have that middle section and I zip it up, and so I'm always in control of it.
但我喜欢它，因为它能轻松装进我买的包里，因为我有那个中间部分，我把它拉上，所以我总是能掌控它。
After talking to the sheriff, Dodie agreed to sponsor a bill that would make it illegal for anyone to bring an imitation firearm to school, to school events, or within 1,000 feet of a school. First time offenders could be fined $250 and sentenced to six months in prison.
在与警长交谈后，多迪同意发起一项法案，规定任何人携带仿制枪支进入学校、学校活动或学校1000英尺范围内都是非法的。初犯者可被罚款250美元并被判处六个月监禁。
Our sheriff did not want one of the officers in Louisiana to shoot a student and have to live with that the rest of their lives.
我们的警长不想让路易斯安那州的任何警察射杀一名学生，然后余生都要带着那个阴影生活。
Of course.
当然。
And the parents, as well. And so that is why I agreed to carry the legislation.
家长也是。所以这就是为什么我同意推动这项立法。
Dodie's legislation became House Bill 43, or HB 43. It went public on March 6, a month before the start of the legislative session. Dodie and the sheriff were interviewed about the bill on talk radio shows around the state. A lot of people thought it seemed totally sensible.
多迪的立法成为第43号众议院法案，或称HB 43。它在3月6日公开，距离立法会议开始还有一个月。多迪和警长在全州的脱口秀广播节目中接受了关于该法案的采访。许多人认为它看起来完全合理。
I don't see anything good that could come in from keeping a right for students-- kids, basically-- to bring these fake guns to school.
我没看到保留学生——基本上是孩子——带这些假枪到学校的权利有什么好处。
That's Don Dubuc on his radio show, More Outdoors. It's a hunting and fishing show. His guests that day were a firearms instructor and the manager of a gun store. Don had run a poll about the bill the day before. 65% of listeners who weighed in were for Dodie's bill. Only 35% were against it, which still surprised one of Don's guests, Devin Burgess. He's the one who manages the gun store.
那是唐·杜布克在他的广播节目《更多户外活动》上。这是一个狩猎和钓鱼节目。他那天邀请的嘉宾是一位枪支教练和一家枪店的经理。唐在前一天对该法案进行了民意调查。65%的听众支持多迪的法案。只有35%的人反对，这仍然让唐的其中一位嘉宾德文·伯吉斯感到惊讶。他就是管理那家枪店的人。
I was surprised how large of an audience was opposed to that. You did a poll during that show, and I think it was 65% to 35%. I don't see any reason that someone would oppose that.
我很惊讶有这么大的受众群体反对它。你在那个节目中做了一次民调，我认为是65%对35%。我不明白有人会反对它的理由。
I think it's a good thing, and we'll see what happens with it. It's House Bill 43, and we'll watch it as it progresses through the session. What else did you guys want to talk about?
我认为这是一件好事，我们将看看它会发生什么。这是第43号众议院法案，我们将在它通过会议期间关注它。你们还想谈论什么？
Well, Devin brought up the three guns you would have during the apocalypse, and I always--
嗯，德文提到了你在世界末日会带的三把枪，我一直——
The three guns you would bring to the apocalypse-- the gun version of what three books would you take to a desert island, only way more practical. The enthusiastic response Dodie got on More Outdoors is not what she remembers about the bill. What she remembers is the backlash she got from her own people, mainly Republicans around the state. This is a radio show called Tom Gresham's Gun Talk.
你在世界末日会带的三把枪——这是“如果去荒岛你会带哪三本书”的枪支版本，只是更实用。多迪在《更多户外活动》中获得的热情回应并不是她对该法案的记忆。她记忆深刻的是她自己的人民，主要是全州的共和党人对她的强烈抵制。这是一个叫《汤姆·格雷沙姆的枪支谈话》的广播节目。
Yeah. And how did Louisiana come to this?
是的。路易斯安那州是怎么变成这样的？
The host, Tom Gresham, was not a fan of Dodie's bill. Gresham lives in Louisiana, but it's a national show.
主持人汤姆·格雷沙姆不是多迪法案的粉丝。格雷沙姆住在路易斯安那州，但这是一个全国性的节目。
Elected lawmakers always feel they must do something. We must do something. That's what we're here for. We have to do something. State representative-- this is Louisiana, Dodie Horton, Republican.
民选议员总是觉得他们必须做点什么。我们必须做点什么。这就是我们来这儿的原因。我们必须做点什么。州代表——这是路易斯安那州，多迪·霍顿，共和党人。
So, she's introduced a bill in the legislature that could put a student in jail for up to six months for bringing a fake gun to a public school or a school event. They say, well, these guns just look real. We can't tell the difference.
所以，她在立法机关提出了一项法案，可能让一名学生因为带假枪进入公立学校或学校活动而入狱六个月。他们说，嗯，这些枪看起来很真实。我们无法分辨区别。
Well, OK. I understand that there's a problem. I understand that you're concerned. But this isn't the way to do it. This has so many downsides.
嗯，好吧。我理解有一个问题。我理解你很关心。但这不是解决它的方法。这有太多的负面影响。
Dodie told me a lot of the concerns she heard on talk radio were about real guns. People thought HB 43 was a gun control bill. She says she went on seven different conservative radio shows in Louisiana to talk about her fake guns bill, and--
多迪告诉我，她在脱口秀广播中听到很多关于真枪的担忧。人们以为HB 43是一项枪支管制法案。她说她去了路易斯安那州七个不同的保守派广播节目谈论她的假枪法案，并且——
It was amazing how I found Republicans eat their own. Republicans were the ones who were coming at me, and just calling me all kind of names, but I'm very thick skinned. I know who I am, and it just blew my mind that they could not wrap their head around imitation-- imitation firearm.
令人惊奇的是，我发现共和党人自相残杀。是共和党人在攻击我，叫我各种名字，但我脸皮很厚。我知道我是谁，让我震惊的是他们无法理解“仿制枪支”这个概念。
They just thought it was just infringing, again, on Second Amendment rights. They thought it was a gun control bill that could be amended in some way to allow real guns to be implemented in it. And I would never have allowed my name to be attached to any bill that implemented gun control in any way.
他们只是认为这又是对第二修正案权利的侵犯。他们认为这是一项枪支管制法案，可以通过某种方式修改以允许真枪被包含在其中。而我绝不会允许我的名字与任何以任何方式实施枪支管制的法案联系在一起。
I mean, did you find yourself just saying, over and over again, these are fake guns we're talking about.
我是说，你是否发现自己一直在反复说，我们讨论的是假枪。
I did, over and over. So I say, have you ever seen one of these imitation firearms? Have you seen it? Have you held it? Has anyone pulled one on you?
我做了，一遍又一遍。所以我说，你见过这些仿制枪支吗？你见过吗？你握过吗？有人用它指着你吗？
What did they say?
他们怎么说？
No. But we still don't like the bill.
没有。但我们仍然不喜欢这个法案。
Dodie was perplexed. She told me she ran the bill past a friend of hers-- a guy who is a state trooper and a firearms instructor, to make sure there wasn't something in it she was just totally missing. She said he couldn't find anything wrong with it, either. But he told her the problem with her critics was--
多迪感到困惑。她告诉我，她把法案拿给她的一个朋友看——一个州警和枪支教练，以确保没有她完全忽略的内容。她说他也找不到什么错，但他也告诉她，她的批评者的问题在于——
They refused to hear. They're refusing to hear because they've heard from the liberal media so much about gun control, they're on edge.
他们拒绝听。他们拒绝听，因为他们从自由派媒体那里听到了太多关于枪支管制的言论，他们处于边缘状态。
Wait, just to break that down for me a little bit more. What is the fear coming out of the liberal media?
等等，为了让我多了解一点。来自自由派媒体的恐惧是什么？
It's gun control. To people that are gun enthusiasts, they just fear that the liberals are coming to get them. They're coming to take our weapons away.
是枪支管制。对枪支发烧友来说，他们只是害怕自由派要来对付他们。他们要来拿走我们的武器。
And so you're a liberal, then? You're the liberal in this case.
所以你是一个自由派？在这一案例中你是自由派。
That's how they were looking at me, and I am just far from that. You know?
他们就是那样看我的，而我离那儿很远。你知道吗？
Dodie was convinced the bill didn't infringe on anyone's Second Amendment rights, but she still tried to reassure people. She said she'd work with the NRA to get their input on the bill. Depending on how you look at this, that move is either obvious-- because hello, the word "gun" is in the bill-- or totally nonsensical, because the word "imitation" precedes the word "gun" in the bill.
多迪确信该法案没有侵犯任何人的第二修正案权利，但她仍然试图安抚人们。她说她会与全国步枪协会（NRA）合作以征求他们对该法案的意见。取决于你怎么看，这一举动要么很明显——因为嘿，法案里有“枪”这个词——要么完全荒谬，因为法案里“仿制”这个词在“枪”这个词之前。
The Second Amendment, of course, gives Americans the right to bear arms, not the right to bear fake arms. But the NRA has a lot of influence in Louisiana. More than 2/3 of Louisiana state legislators have a grade of A-minus or better from the NRA. Even Dodie, who's always packing, only got a B from them. So she got in touch with Art Thomm. He was the NRA's lobbyist in Louisiana at the time. She said she spent about a week working with him.
当然，第二修正案赋予美国人持枪权，而不是携带假武器的权利。但NRA在路易斯安那州有很大的影响力。超过三分之二的路易斯安那州州立法者在NRA的评级中获得A-或更高。即使是总是随身带着枪的多迪也只从他们那里得到了一个B。所以她联系了阿特·托姆。他是当时NRA在路易斯安那州的游说者。她说她花了一周左右的时间和他一起工作。
The NRA had come back to me and said, we just can't get on board. I said, give me a reason why. We just don't like it. And I said, but it's an imitation firearm. And so I said, well, if you take no position, then that's fine.
NRA回来找我说，我们就是无法支持。我说，给我一个理由。我们就是不喜欢它。我说，但这是仿制枪支。所以我说，嗯，如果你们不持立场，那也没关系。
No position. Her goal was just to get the NRA to officially take no position, which is actually kind of like taking a position-- one that says, we're neutral on this. Make up your own minds about it. But they wouldn't do it. Instead, they just said nothing about the bill, which indicated to their supporters and to legislators that they should oppose HB 43.
不持立场。她的目标只是让NRA正式采取“不持立场”的态度，这实际上有点像是一种立场——一种说，我们在这一点上是中立的立场。你们自己决定吧。但他们做不到。相反，他们只是对法案只字未提，这向他们的支持者和立法者表明他们应该反对HB 43。
When I first heard about this story, the main thing that interested me was the possibility that the NRA was opposing the fake guns bill on Second Amendment grounds-- that they believed Dodie's bill might somehow erode or endanger our right to own real guns. The NRA has opposed fake and toy gun laws in California, New Jersey, and Maryland.
当我第一次听到这个故事时，主要吸引我的是NRA以第二修正案为由反对假枪法案的可能性——他们认为多迪的法案可能会以某种方式削弱或危及我们拥有真枪的权利。NRA在加利福尼亚、新泽西和马里兰州反对过假枪和玩具枪法律。
The NRA wouldn't agree to an interview with me about this, so I can't say for sure if they're doing this out of a fear of gun control. Fortunately, the president of the Louisiana Shooting Association did talk to me. They're an independent organization affiliated with the NRA. Their president's name is Dan Zelenka, and he was unambiguous about Dodie's bill.
NRA不愿接受关于此事的采访，所以我无法肯定他们是否是出于对枪支管制的恐惧。幸运的是，路易斯安那州射击协会主席确实和我谈了。他们是一个隶属于NRA的独立组织。他们的主席名叫丹·泽连卡，他对多迪的法案立场明确。
It clearly was treated as a gun control bill.
它显然被视为一项枪支管制法案。
While the national NRA wouldn't take a stand on Dodie's bill, the Louisiana Shooting Association flat out opposed it. When Dan first read the bill, he was shocked to see Dodie's name on it.
虽然全国性的NRA不会对多迪的法案表态，但路易斯安那州射击协会直接反对它。当丹第一次读到该法案时，看到多迪的名字在上面他感到很震惊。
I sent her an email immediately, saying, what gives? Because this is not you.
我立即给她发了电子邮件，说，是怎么回事？因为这不像你。
Yeah. What did she write back?
是啊。她回信说什么？
Thank you for contacting me. I am and will always be a strong Second Amendment activist. This bill does not infringe on our gun rights, blah, blah, blah, blah. OK.
感谢你联系我。我过去是，将来也会一直是坚定的第二修正案活动家。这个法案没有侵犯我们的枪支权利，等等等等。好的。
I asked her, what exactly are you trying to accomplish with this? Because there may be a way to accomplish it without having any kind of anti-gun, even though it's a toy gun, but anti-gun implications.
我问她，你到底想通过这个实现什么？因为可能有一种方法可以实现它，而没有任何反枪支的含义，即使它是玩具枪，但反枪支的含义。
How does a bill about toy guns lead to a fear about real guns?
一个关于玩具枪的法案怎么会导致对真枪的恐惧？
Let me try to figure out how to put this correctly.
让我试着弄清楚如何正确地表达。
OK.
好的。
Even though it doesn't actually impinge on or infringe on Second Amendment rights, OK, there's no actual infringement, but there's an appearance of infringement. Does that make sense?
尽管它实际上并没有损害或侵犯第二修正案权利，好的，没有任何实际侵犯，但存在侵犯的外表。这有意义吗？
Dan says the problem with a bill like this isn't that it chips away at gun rights, directly. The problem is about messaging. A bill like this might send the message that guns are inherently bad, and this fear lies at the heart of a battle going on between gun rights people and gun control people-- a battle for attitudes, Dan calls it.
丹说，像这样的法案的问题不在于它直接削弱了枪支权利。问题在于信息传递。像这样的法案可能会传递出“枪本身是坏的”这样的信息，这种恐惧构成了枪支权利支持者和枪支管制支持者之间正在进行的战斗的核心——丹称之为态度之争。
He brought up a speech that Obama's attorney general, Eric Holder, gave in 1995, years before he was the attorney general. Gun rights people refer to this speech a lot. In it, Holder lays out a vision for combating gun violence-- an information campaign.
他提到了奥巴马的总检察长埃里克·霍尔德在1995年发表的一次演讲，那是在他担任总检察长之前几年。枪支权利支持者经常引用这个演讲。在演讲中，霍尔德提出了打击枪支暴力的愿景——一个信息宣传活动。
And what we need to do is change the way in which people think about guns, especially young people, and make it something that's not cool-- that it's not acceptable. It's not hip to carry a gun any more, in the way in which we've changed our attitudes about cigarettes.
我们需要做的是改变人们看待枪支的方式，尤其是年轻人，让它变得不是那种酷的——不可接受的。携带枪支不再是时髦的了，就像我们改变了对香烟的态度一样。
He goes on to say that he's asked ad agencies to help them with this.
他继续说，他已经请广告公司帮助他们。
It's not enough to simply have a catchy ad on a Monday and then only do it every Monday. We need to do this every day of the week, and just really brainwash people into thinking about guns in a vastly different way.
仅仅在周一有一个引人注目的广告，然后只在每周一做是不够的。我们需要一周中的每一天都这样做，并真正给人们洗脑，让他们以一种完全不同的方式思考枪支。
That word, brainwash, is kind of a trigger for gun rights people-- no pun intended. And even though Holder was talking specifically about getting guns off the streets in Washington, DC, where he was the US attorney at the time, this idea that gun control groups are trying to brainwash kids into disliking guns-- that's enough to raise red flags over a bill like Dodie's.
那个词，“洗脑”，对枪支权利支持者来说是一种触发——没别的意思。即使霍尔德当时专门谈论的是在华盛顿特区把枪支清出街道——他在那里是联邦检察官——这种认为枪支管制团体试图给孩子们洗脑，让他们不喜欢枪支的观点——这对多迪这样的法案来说已经足以引发危险信号了。
I just think criminalizing mere possession of a toy, without having somebody committing a crime-- I just don't think we have any place for it.
我只是认为仅仅因为拥有玩具而将某人定为刑事犯罪，而没有某人实施犯罪——我不认为我们有任何地方适用这一点。
And what does that indicate to you, in terms of society? You brought up Eric Holder.
就社会而言，这表明了什么？你提到了埃里克·霍尔德。
I am not sure what that indicates, exactly. But a five-year-old kid was suspended from school for eating his Pop-Tart into the shape of a gun.
我不确定这确切表明了什么。但一个五岁的孩子因为把Pop-Tart（果酱馅饼）咬成了枪的形状而被停课。
Yeah.
是啊。
So, if that is not brainwashing that guns are bad, I'm not sure what.
所以，如果这不是在洗脑枪支是坏的，我不知道是什么。
This Pop-Tart he's talking about is probably the most famous Pop-Tart that ever existed. It was chewed into the shape of a gun by a second grader in Maryland. He was seven, by the way, not five. He was suspended from school for two days, which led to a slew of so-called, Pop-Tart gun bills, in which state legislators passed laws saying that kids couldn't be punished in schools for imaginary gun play.
他谈论的这个Pop-Tart可能是历史上最著名的Pop-Tart。它被马里兰州的一名二年级学生咬成了枪的形状。顺便说一句，他七岁，不是五岁。他因为被学校停课两天，这导致了一系列所谓的“Pop-Tart枪支法案”，各州立法者通过法律规定孩子们不能因为想象中的枪支游戏而在学校受到惩罚。
Dan says in this battle for attitudes, if you're writing a bill that criminalizes imitation guns, that's sending the message that guns are bad. And he says that's not the only reason the Louisiana Shooting Association was opposed to Dodie's fake guns bill. They also thought that local school boards should be the ones deciding what to do if a kid brought a fake gun to school, not state legislators.
丹说，在这场态度之争中，如果你写了一项将仿制枪支定为犯罪的法案，那就是在传递枪支是坏的信息。他说，这就是路易斯安那州射击协会反对多迪假枪法案的唯一原因。他们还认为，如果孩子带假枪到学校，应该由当地学区委员会决定该做什么，而不是州立法者。
And they also thought the law wasn't necessary, because any kid who threatened someone else with a fake gun can still be charged with assault, even if they can't be charged for having a weapon, like the sheriff wanted. Of course, the NRA is running their own campaign in this battle for attitudes.
他们还认为这项法律没有必要，因为任何用假枪威胁别人的人仍然可以被指控袭击罪，即使他们不能像警长想要的那样因为携带武器被指控。当然，NRA正在这场态度之争中进行自己的运动。
All right, I love toy guns. Even at 47, I still play with toy guns with my 7-year-old son. I also play with my real guns, too. The anti-gun left, though, as you can imagine, doesn't just hate real guns, it hates all guns-- even fun, toy laser guns that my 7-year-old happens to play with for hours.
好了，我喜欢玩具枪。即使在47岁，我仍然和我的7岁儿子一起玩玩具枪。我也玩我的真枪。然而，反枪支的左派，如你所想象的，不仅讨厌真枪，还讨厌所有的枪——甚至是我的7岁儿子碰巧玩了好几个小时的有趣的玩具激光枪。
This is Grant Stinchfield. He hosts a show on NRA TV, the NRA's 24 hours a day, seven days a week broadcast network. They have 36 shows that stream on their website and on satellite radio, including one hosted by Oliver North. Here's Stinchfield.
这是格兰特·斯廷奇菲尔德。他主持了NRA电视节目，这是NRA全天24小时、一周七天的广播网络。他们在他们的网站和卫星广播上有36个节目，包括一个由奥利弗·诺斯主持的节目。这是斯廷奇菲尔德。
The latest article is written by a gay dad for a gay publication. He ends his piece saying, quote, "I am well aware that toy guns aren't the same as real guns, but the way I see it, they both kill people, even if it's only in our imagination. And I'm not OK with that. Not on my watch." Only a liberal can think killing in your imagination and killing in real life are the same thing. They aren't. Stop wussifying our children. Let boys be boys. It worked for me.
最新的文章是由一位同性恋父亲为一份同性恋出版物写的。他以这篇文章结尾说，引用：“我很清楚玩具枪和真枪不一样，但以我看，它们都会杀人，即使这只是在我们的想象中。我不赞同这一点。不在我的监督下。”只有自由派才会认为想象中的杀戮和现实生活中的杀戮是一回事。它们不是。停止把我们的孩子变软弱。让男孩做男孩。这对我有效。
So, yeah. The NRA is putting up a fight of its own in this battle for attitudes. Besides NRA TV, they have at least eight Twitter accounts, five magazines, seven content producing web sites, and a lifestyle brand they call NRA Country, an attempt to attract young people by connecting the NRA to country music stars.
所以，是的。NRA正在这场态度之争中进行自己的战斗。除了NRA电视，他们至少有八个推特账号、五本杂志、七个内容制作网站，以及一个他们称之为NRA乡村的生活方式品牌，这是一个试图通过将NRA与乡村音乐明星联系起来来吸引年轻人的尝试。
But anyway, back to Louisiana-- springtime, 2017. Dodie pre-filed her bill, and it pretty quickly got the attention of a state representative named Blake Miguez. He's considered one of the go to guys for gun rights stuff in Louisiana-- keeps his eye on everything that's being proposed.
但无论如何，回到路易斯安那州——2017年春天。多迪预先提交了她的法案，它很快引起了一位名叫布莱克·米格斯的州代表的注意。他被认为是路易斯安那州枪支权利问题的负责人之一——关注着所有被提议的事项。
See, what I'll do is I can search the bills that are gun related, and I'll look and I'll see-- let's say there's 15 that pop up. But I like to do that every session.
你看，我会做的是我可以搜索枪支相关的法案，我会看——假设有15个弹出来。但我喜欢在每届会议都这样做。
So he's doing that, and he sees Dodie's bill.
所以他正在做那个，他看到了多迪的法案。
And I know that she is a supporter of firearms. There's no point in-- I know that she's not passing a piece of legislation, or I'd like to believe and presume she's not going to pass a piece of legislation that's anti-gun. So I'm going, is this a gun issue or is this not a gun issue? It looks and it smells like a Second Amendment bill, but it's not actually one.
我知道她是一个枪支支持者。没必要——我知道她不会通过一项立法，或者我愿意相信和假设她不会通过一项反枪支的立法。所以我说，这是一个枪支问题吗，还是一个非枪支问题？它看起来和闻起来像第二修正案法案，但实际上不是。
It was the imitation part of the imitation guns bill that threw Blake for a loop. In the end, Blake decided the bill didn't threaten the Second Amendment, but he was still against it for some of the same reasons as the Louisiana Shooting Association. But he also gave Dodie some advice about the NRA.
正是仿制枪支法案中的“仿制”部分让布莱克陷入了困境。最后，布莱克决定该法案没有威胁第二修正案，但他仍然出于与路易斯安那州射击协会相同的一些原因反对它。但他确实给了多迪一些关于NRA的建议。
It's hard to pass a piece of legislation that is perceived to deal with guns without the NRA's support.
如果不获得NRA的支持，很难通过一项被认为涉及枪支的立法。
Blake said, you don't want to go against them. If the NRA opposes it, then it validates the other Republicans' fears that it's a bad bill. And he's right. He was right.
布莱克说，你不想对抗他们。如果NRA反对它，那就证实了其他共和党人对它是一项坏法案的恐惧。他是对的。他是对的。
By the time Dodie got to Baton Rouge for the start of the legislative session in April, she had the impression her bill was doomed-- that it wouldn't make it out of committee.
当多迪在四月份到达巴吞鲁日开始立法会议时，她已感觉到她的法案注定失败——它无法通过委员会。
What was the advice you got from your fellow Republican legislators when you were having this backlash? What advice did they give you?
当你遭受这种反弹时，你的共和党立法同僚给了你什么建议？他们给了你什么建议？
Drop the bill. Pull the bill. You're our friend. We don't want you to go down on this. It will not pass committee.
撤回法案。撤掉它。你是我们的朋友。我们不想看到你在这件事上栽跟头。它通不过委员会。
What were they worried would happen to you if you kept at it?
他们担心如果你继续坚持会发生什么？
They just felt that I would be ostracized in some way, possibly. They didn't want to see me being known within the Louisiana Republican Party as someone that needs to go-- that I've just crossed a line as a Republican.
他们只是觉得我可能会以某种方式被排挤。他们不想看到我被路易斯安那州共和党内知晓为一个需要走人的人——我作为共和党人已经越线了。
So Dodie pulled the bill. She made the decision after meeting with some members of the Criminal Justice Committee, where she had planned to introduce it.
所以多迪撤回了法案。她在会见了刑事司法委员会的一些成员后做出了决定，她原本打算在那里介绍它。
I felt defeated. I look at timing and open doors-- they were shut when I walked in that capitol. They said, look, we understand it's imitation, but the public doesn't. And I'm going, golly, guys. Not you, too. Not y'all, too.
我感到失败了。我看待时机和敞开的门——当我走进那个国会大厦时，它们是关闭的。他们说，看，我们明白它是仿制的，但公众不明白。我就说，天哪，伙计们。连你们也是。连你们也是。
She never thought it would come to this. An NRA loving, Trump Republican with a loaded Glock in her purse. Somehow, she wasn't Republican enough. Some people even used one of the worst insults you can sling at a person like Dodie.
她从没想过会到这一步。一个热爱NRA、支持特朗普的共和党人，包里带着一把上了膛的格洛克。不知何故，她不够共和党。有些人甚至使用了你可以朝多迪这样的人扔出的最糟糕的侮辱之一。
They called her a RINO, which, of course, stands for Republican In Name Only. It stung. She felt betrayed. She felt let down by her fellow gun rights supporters and by her fellow Republicans across the state.
他们叫她RINO，当然，意思是“名义上的共和党人”。这刺痛了她。她感到被背叛了。她感到被全州的枪支权利支持者和共和党同僚辜负了。
They turned on me. I felt that my own party turned on me, and I never have experienced that before. And it was unreal.
他们背叛了我。我感到我自己的党背叛了我，我从未经历过那种事。而且它是不真实的。
The fake guns bill lived and died in a matter of five weeks, and if now, in retrospect, that seems inevitable, consider what happened in Dodie's own district, Bossier Parish, months before she sponsored HB 43.
假枪法案在五周内生生死死，如果现在回顾起来，这似乎是不可避免的，考虑一下在多迪发起HB 43之前几个月，多迪自己的选区博西尔教区发生了什么。
A local version of the fake guns bill came up in the parish government-- it's like a city council-- and it passed, unanimously. Sheriff Whittington was behind the local ordinance, same as he was behind Dodie's statewide bill.
假枪法案的一个本地版本在教区政府中出现——就像市议会一样——它一致通过了。惠廷顿警长在本地条例背后支持，就像他支持多迪的全州法案一样。
Did you have any push back, locally?
你在本地有任何抵制吗？
Not a bit.
一点都没有。
Everyone was on board with it?
每个人都对此表示支持？
Not one bit of resistance.
一点点抵制都没有。
And it's not like you're in some gun hating liberal pocket of Louisiana.
而且这不像你在路易斯安那州某个讨厌枪支的自由派口袋里。
No, we're not. We're probably one of the-- out of all the parishes, probably the top three most conservative parishes in the state.
不，我们不是。我们可能是——在所有教区中，可能是该州前三个最保守的教区之一。
It passed in the parish and not the state house because, first of all, generally, nobody pays attention to local politics. So, the whole discussion took place outside the hyper-charged, us versus them, never give an inch battleground, where so much of the rest of our politics takes place. The Bossier Parish sheriff said he wanted the ordinance. The parish lawyer assured everyone it did not imply they were anti-Second Amendment, and voila, as they used to say in those parts. It passed.
它在教区通过而不是州议会通过，因为首先，通常情况下，没人关注地方政治。所以，整个讨论发生在超额、你争我斗、寸步不让的战场之外，我们政治的其余大部分都在那里发生。博西尔教区警长说他想要这个条例。教区律师向大家保证，这并不意味着他们是反第二修正案的，voila（瞧），就像他们过去在那些地方常说的那样。它通过了。
What happened to Dodie at the statehouse was just the normal, run of the mill way that so much political debate is snuffed out in this country. Liberals see a bill that restricts abortions in any way, and they're automatically and unequivocally against it. Conservatives hear about legislation that expands any rights for undocumented immigrants, and the conversation is ended before it's begun.
多迪在州议会发生的事情只是这个国家如此多政治辩论被扼杀的正常、司空见惯的方式。自由派看到一项以任何方式限制堕胎的法案，他们自动且毫无疑问地反对它。保守派听到关于扩大任何无证移民权利的立法，谈话在开始之前就结束了。
We often don't even get to the point of agreeing that there might be a problem worth fixing because we're so scared the other side will get to decide the solution. Maybe Dodie's bill, in the form it was in, wasn't the best way to resolve the problem the sheriff was facing, but the problem the Sheriff was facing was certainly a problem worth discussing.
我们往往甚至无法达到同意可能有值得解决的问题的程度，因为我们太害怕对方会决定解决方案。也许多迪的法案，以那种形式，并不是解决警长面临的问题的最佳方式，但警长面临的问题无疑是一个值得讨论的问题。
Dana Chivvis is one of the producers of our show.
达娜·奇维斯是我们节目的制片人之一。
For our program-- was produced today by Stephanie Foo. The people who put this show together include Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Damien Gray, Kimberly Henderson, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Miki Meek, Alvin Melathe, Ben Phelan, Robyn Semien, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our managing editor is Susan Burton.
我们的节目——今天由斯蒂芬妮·福制作。把这个节目汇集在一起的人包括佐伊·蔡斯、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、达米安·格雷、金伯利·亨德森、查纳·乔夫-沃尔特、大卫·克斯滕鲍姆、米基·米克、阿尔文·梅拉斯、本·费兰、罗宾·塞米恩、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。我们的高级制片人是布莱恩·里德。我们的总编辑是苏珊·伯顿。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, I have to remind him sometimes that I am really, actually in charge of the radio show. His response is always the same.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心PRX分发给公共广播电台。一如既往，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，我有时得提醒他，我才真正负责这个广播节目。他的回应总是相同的。
(SINGING) The patriarchy is raging.
（唱歌）父权制正在肆虐。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。